all right uh another topic and this
relates to the browns and the jets a
couple of players on social media
getting into
fights with fans jerome whitehead or
jermaine right head excuse me over the
top to the point where he's been cut by
the browns he had some awful things he
said last night on twitter directed to
brown's fans the team issued a statement
calling the tweets on social media
totally unacceptable highly
inappropriate we immediately spoke with
jermaine upon learning of these comments
the browns in no way condone that type
of language or behavior this matter will
be further addressed internally that was
last night but today whitehead is gone
same thing happened for the jets
cornerback daryl roberts posted some
stuff on twitter our social media i'm
not sure whether it was twitter or
instagram or what i'm sorry but it's got
to be said all y'all fake ass fans
effing kill me with that negative sh
bleep tee if you're gonna ro you know
we've already cursed galore on this i
don't know what like alarm i don't know
why we're being careful
if we're gonna if you're gonna rock with
us then rock with this but it ain't if
if it if you ain't shut
the f up please and go like another team
that's daryl roberts and
it's it's just amazing how social media
has become such a driving force in the
existence
of folks in their teens and 20s and even
like you know i i look in and see what
the interaction is you can't get upset
about that you got to learn
that you you gain nothing by giving into
that temptation to fight someone
definitely i mean what what what the
hell come on i mean first of all
jermaine whitehead what the hell are you
doing i mean that was just like that you
couldn't that couldn't be dumber it's
more stupid he i mean he there's a good
chance he never sees the nfl again
because of that and what i want to say
to all players is why the hell are you
getting in the locker room and checking
social media right away like you're like
cool off take a shower process the game
but they do it right away i know and
it's because it shows you that social
media is addictive it's i mean we know
this these are these are real issues
it's it's affecting our whole country
it's affecting our whole world and i
just don't get it and especially as an
especially especially people are driving
in their cars checking social media well
you you know that drives me crazy i mean
they should be arrested and thrown in
jail for the night i mean i'm sick of
that too if i have to drive one guy buy
one more guy in the fast lane who's on
instagram or on facebook why he's going
70 i mean really they should be like i
want to be like there should be a public
stoning for that you're going to put us
all a danger because you got to check
what's cool on instagram but as a nfl
player what the hell are you doing who
gives a damn which a bunch of fans who
really don't understand the game and its
full completeness anyways and are just
emotional about the loss too why are you
even giving it credence i just don't
understand it just it's like you got to
be smarter than us players and and
especially if you're not a superstar
player you're not going gonna win that
battle if you're a bottom of the roster
player your ass is gonna get cut and i
mean daryl roberts he probably hangs in
there because he's
more of a a vital piece to that defense
but
um yeah i mean he's certainly gonna get
a talking dude today by the jets and i
mean he does something like that again i
bet you his butt gets cut too
i'm sorry are you saying something as
there's a funny dog video oh yeah of
course yeah yeah that's what you do
that's what you do
but you're right there's a point where
you got to be able to control yourself
and
i don't know how much coaching goes into
this what kind of messages are sent to
the players because this is the kind of
stuff that you would think would be
avoidable now for a team that can't get
out of its own way like the browns and
the jets this is very far down on the
list of priorities but
you wonder is it a chicken and egg type
of thing is this why they suck do they
have too many guys in the locker room
who have like this miswiring in their
brains and they're not properly focused
on the things that they should focus on
like we're never going to hear anything
like this happen with the patriots
you're not going to have a story on a
monday watch it's going to happen now no
never have a story on a monday that
somebody from the patriots decided to
launch into a twitter tirade because
even though bill belichick acts like he
doesn't know what social media is he
knows what it is yeah and he's going to
know if you do something you shouldn't
do and if you do something you shouldn't
do your ass is gone yeah no it's it's i
mean it's it's laid out in simple terms
just
in new england you you know what you can
and can't do from this moment you step
in that door and you conform or they get
you out of there and they don't need you
i mean just like what they did to
michael bennett i mean look how much
money did they give michael bennett they
gave me how many how many million
signing bonus four or five million
dollar signing photos see you later yeah
see you later hey they did antonio brown
right antonio and i
add him into the conversation what the
hell are you doing nobody wants to sign
you in the league and all of a sudden
antonio clown becomes the thing of the
halloween and you like he's got to
attack all those people on social media
which is only going to invite people to
do stuff like that more because they're
going to go oh look i'm some idiot from
wherever
and i'm somebody from new jersey and
they've got nothing more than debate
skin this is awesome yeah he's actually
mad at me
from new jersey
i mean like whatever that's just that is
the one thing to remember if you're in
the public eye if you have a significant
following on social media they are
trying to bait you because that's going
to make their day if you respond to them
if you react to them and it is a very
potent temptation it's hard i know and
uh i'm sure do you give in to it from
time to time i do it's a good thing the
the best thing i have going for me is
and i do i flip through my social media
but i try not to tweet directly uh more
times than not and if and when i do want
to send a tweet out i send it to
actually somebody here at nbc as you
know matt casey who then kind of looks
at it and he's my filter because i can
get emotional just like players can too
i get it you know sometimes a guy
attacks me and i want to be like man
you're so wrong in everything you said
but i can't really i just can't deal
with it and it's just it is it's
frustrating but hey live in the moment
enjoy life around you not everybody gets
stuck in their phone and their ipad all
the time and reading all this crap as
you watch this video on your phone that
would be the great irony well this is
not social media we're talking about
something at least irrelevant to
football news and like having a
conversation about it which you
shouldn't do but yeah
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports